joining us now is the president of the
United States President Trump sir good
to have you back on the program
hi Shawn you know I watched you last
night you seem to really love doing what
you did last night
explained you know why is this important
to you and why there is a phenomenon
that people show up at your rallies we
don't see the same thing at the
democratic rallies why is that in your
view there was tremendous energy in that
room last night there was and we've had
a lot of energy and virtually every
every rally but there was just a special
energy I announced we're going forward
with the second term as you know but the
level of it was like being at a world
championship college football game where
the score was tied going into the last
minute it was the entire rally it was an
incredible scene and outside there were
thousands of people and I mean we were
asking people not to show up where say
please don't come letting the word out
because we had a hundred and twenty-one
thousand people before I guess it holds
20 or 25,000 people inside of you
include the basketball court which was
loaded up with great loving Patriots
and it was just an electric evening
shown you know III want to ask you I
don't know if you saw a show on Monday
but Monday we had our friend Lawrence
Jones down there or I guess it was a
Tuesday night but knows Monday and we
will it looked like a tailgating party
and people there 40 45 hours in the
pouring we're hidden for the event I
actually kind of regretted not going
because I wanted to hang out with the
people outside because they were having
a blast they're people that love our
country and they love seeing what's
happening and it was in a way a tailgate
party for the country not for a team
although it's a team when you think
about it but it's a tailgate party for
our country and it was just the feeling
was it was like love but
love for what we're all about for the
things we stand for it was a beautiful
it was a beautiful evening it was and
even the enemies and you know we have a
lot of people that don't like us so much
you possibly have heard about that Joe
and I'm not going to write about the
hastily what's people saying it was yes
a lot of us say they've never seen
anything quite like it it was special
and you know it's pourin they had a
monsoon and I don't think I don't think
one person walked off line they had they
had a rain like you haven't seen and it
didn't nobody left they just sat there
and stood there and some brought tents
they were there for two days waiting to
get in try to believe me I bought a
painting from this guy in Utah his name
is John McNaughton and it was called the
forgotten man I have the original copy I
paid a lot of money for it and I bought
it because it mattered to me and if you
recall in 2015 and 2016 I told everybody
what the Biden Obama record was after
eight years I said it almost every day
I'm radio and TV for a year 13 million
more Americans on food stamps 8 million
more in poverty worse recovery since the
40s lowest homeownership rate in 51
years lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s more debt than 43
presidents before them combined and they
never hit one year three percent GDP
growth for a year right and those are
all real people you talked at length
about record low unemployment the best
employment situation from 1969 I know
that the media talks about Russia still
after four investigations they want a
fifth but what does it mean to you that
thing we have now two million more jobs
available than people that are on
unemployment what does that mean to you
well the media is not talking about
Russia so much you know the Muller
report concluded that on Russia there
was absolutely no collusion and frankly
they led to the conclusion by our great
Attorney General that there was no
obstruction the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard of it's a hoax it was a
hoax a witch-hunt but a hope
the whole thing Gregg Jarrett said it
very well what he named his book the
Russian hoax and it is disgraceful that
they're allowed and they're very upset
now because it didn't turn out like they
thought because we did we had 18 angry
Democrats that hated krump and many of
them contributed to Hillary's campaign
and it came out there was no collision
so they don't I don't hear Russia much
anymore you know they've given up on
that one but you know they they did
something that is a disgrace I will also
say if the other side had won if Hillary
won you would have instead of being up
almost 50% since election five million
jobs plus plus five million jobs that's
unthinkable if I would have said that
we're going to create five million jobs
in two and a half years people would
have said how ridiculous would have been
skewered by the press all of the things
that have been done that we've done
nobody has seen it we have the best
lowest unemployment rate for African
Americans for Asians for Hispanics
nobody's ever seen numbers like this we
have the the best numbers on living
standard for African Americans the best
numbers that we've ever had in history
so many things are I mean just one thing
after another if the other side would
have won we would have gone into a
depression
and we were headed that way we were
headed that way the rules regulations we
cut more regulations than any president
and unmeaning 'fl regulation we want
regulation but it's got to be meaningful
it stymied our country showing we
weren't able to do anything jobs numbers
would have been a disaster instead we
have more people working today almost a
hundred and sixty million people than
have ever worked in the history of our
country think of that that's a great
number so it's really been something the
other side you would have had I really
believe you would have had a crash you
know mr. president I come from
blue-collar roots ten years in the
restaurant business at twelve I was
washing dishes by hand ten years in the
construction business every job
imaginable so I really identify with
The Forgotten man and women and I think
everybody in this job and the media were
overpaid and most of them are lazy and I
just want to you know when you think
back and those statistics I just gave
you it spits thirteen million eight
million
those are real American citizens real
lives and now they're really doing
better and I think one of the best
things that is understated is we are for
the first time in 75 years energy
independent which means we don't have to
go kissing the ass of countries that
don't like us and we don't and we are
now a net exporter of energy and by the
way if Putin remains hostile and Russia
remains hostile I think we out producer
them and we bring their economy to its
knees
well we're now number one in the world
and energy used to be Saudi Arabia then
Russia it's now we're number one and
soon as soon as I get the pipelines and
Texas approved which I'll do pretty
quickly it would have taken 10 15 years
I'm gonna have it done very quickly we
could increase our production by 30 and
40 percent in terms of sale so it's you
know what what we've done in the last
two and a half years has been great
we've had a lot of great people and
they've worked hard but the great people
are the people of the country they were
they were being strangled you look at
what we've done just energy all energy
all over all types of energy LNG now is
with the hottest in the world there's
nobody even close so it's been an honor
it's been an honor we freed it up but
you would have had I really believe you
would have had a depression or very
close at these decide one mr. mr.
president all this Devin Nunez wrote a
column who was former House ranking
member of the House Intel
14 warning the Biden Obama
administration about Russia interference
in the 2016 election he laid it out
perfectly in 2014 this all happened on
their watch yeah all of it happened on
their watch and my question to you is
there really was some collusion wasn't
there there was Russian interference we
know that but we also had a bought and
paid for
rushon dossier and we didn't look into
that in the whole two plus years of
Muller the media's ignored it and even
the New York Times suggesting that it
was likely Russian misinformation from
the get-go the dossier what are your
thoughts about that I think it's a
disgrace
it's turned out to be totally
discredited the steel was sued by
somebody I understand a wealthy
gentleman in in London I hear that what
was revealed was incredible had just a
total phony deal and yet they didn't
look into any of that one of the things
that amazes me because it's so simple
and you know it's it's when you get
right down to it the whole thing is very
simple what happened the fact is they
were spying on my campaign using
agencies to intelligence agencies to do
it going after Paige and Papadopoulos
and probably others I'm trying to we're
trying to find out whether or not they
actually listened in on my calls that'll
be the that would be the ultimate we'll
see what happens I think if if that
happened we'll probably find out we have
a great attorney general who's working
very hard and we'll see what happens I
stay uninvolved I like to stay
uninvolved but a lot of things are going
to come out I mean if they spied on my
campaign and they may have it will be
one of the great revelations of
revelations in in history of this
country and I will tell you going to be
very interesting I think we're going to
find out can you imagine if it were the
other way around and I spied on
President Obama's campaign could you
imagine what the repercussions would be
or I spied on crooked Hillary's campaign
can you imagine what the repercussions
would be let me ask you specifically I
want to stay on this topic because I
think this abuse of power is very
dangerous you addressed it last night
sir your campaign was spied on in
October 2016 Hillary's dossier bought
and paid for Russian dossier paid for by
her and the money she controlled
the DNC that was funneled through a law
firm that hired a research group that
hired a foreign national we now know
that Bruce or testified behind closed
doors that everybody was warned that
Christopher Steele hated you that
Hillary paid for it and that it was not
verified that was August 2 2016 14 days
before Jim Comey signed the first FISA
application and a 5s application I'm
told says the word verified on it before
he signed it he was warned by Kathleen
calves lack of the State Department who
met with Christopher Steele so my
question to you is your spied on as a
candidate during your transition as
president and then abroad we had Stephan
halper spying on Carter page Sam Clovis
George papadopolis so those are just
ways that we've already verified it's
not in dispute anymore your campaign was
spied on your transition was spied on
Jim called me three months after he
signed that warrant verifying the
Russian dossier bulk of information is
true he then came to Trump Tower and
told you it's salacious but unverified
the opposite of what he was telling the
court do you believe that there was a
premeditated fraud committed against
FISA Court judges in these applications
well again people are looking into that
if you're asking just my opinion I would
say absolutely yes it would seem to be
yes and you know when you get the struck
page the two lovers who put right out on
the public waves I mean they put the
insurance policy well we've been living
through the insurance policy that she
was going to win but just in case she
didn't win we need an insurance policy
well that's to subvert government what
they did was unbelievable that they
could do a thing like that and they
reported to McCabe who I think is a
terrible terrible guy and you know the
FBI you have some of the finest people
in the world that you know that we say
it all the time and I'll bet you if we
took a vote
I'd be so high in that poll you wouldn't
even believe it there's great people I
know so many but the top people were
terrible they were leakers they were
liars I mean look at the leaking and
look at the lying call me admitted he
leaked think of it the top of the FBI he
leaked and when you look at what went on
John it's disgusting but the whole
concept of they wanted insurance policy
just in case she loses well that's why
we've lived through we've lived through
the insurance policy and yet the House
Committee which I understand today was
in a very closed confidential meeting
with the wonderful hope if she's a
wonderful person well she's been through
hell they put this young woman through
hell what she's had to pay for legal
fees and everything else yeah they were
taking pictures of her congressman to
congressman in particular that I see on
television all the time I won't mention
their names we don't want to make him
any more famous but to congressman but
they were taking pictures of her with a
cell phone and then leaking the pictures
of her testifying and this was in a
closed room look it's out of control
these people are absolutely you know
they use it they use the word it's a
good word I guess unhinged what's
happened to the Democrats and in the
meantime they're not doing any work in
Congress we could do legislation to
lower drug prices very substantially
easily we could do maybe almost like the
thing we need the most quickly is border
security we've done an incredible job
but I have to do it myself I can't get
any we can't get any votes from the
Democrats we can't get any votes and
infrastructure we could do it so easily
but they're so busy interviewing kopecks
and taking pictures of this incredible
young woman and putting the pictures out
to the press of her testifying and
they're not allowed to do that it's
probably illegal it's a terrible thing
going on John the SIRT there have been
four separate investigations let me
remind you the nine-month FBI
investigation the one that Peter struck
said there's no there there
lisa page said we had nothing after nine
months as it relates to collusion then
there was the house Intel committee
investigation no collusion then the
bipartisan Senate committee no collusion
then the Muller report directly quoted
it no collusion no conspiracy you I had
wanted you I'm a talk show host so I
sometimes do straight news we do
investigative reporting sometimes sports
and culture and I give strong
conservative opinions I've been a
conservative all my career we don't hide
that fact what I have wanted you to
declassify the 302s declassify all this
information the FISA applications
declassify the gang of eight declassify
exculpatory information you have done so
but you gave it to the Attorney General
why yes because I think that he is a
very honorable gentleman who wants to do
the right thing and he is allowed to
under my agreement he's allowed to give
it out to whoever he wants but I think
it's really you know maybe some of this
you need to have for purposes of other
countries because I think other
countries were involved I think they
perhaps just based on what I'm saying
they used other countries because they
didn't want to get caught doing what
they were doing in this country you know
that very well
so I'm presently general bill Barr he's
got it totally everything that I can do
in terms of opening it up and make it
transparent as the politicians like to
use that word transparent I'm the most
transparent president in history I let
Muller have everything they wanted if
you think of it 500 witnesses interview
our attorneys interview whoever you want
I think 2500 subpoenas I didn't use
presidential privilege because I didn't
speak to Russia Russia has what I was
winning in Wisconsin when I was winning
in Michigan in Pennsylvania and Ohio and
Florida and all of these states North
Carolina the last person or group I ever
thought of colleague would be Russia
it's a hoax
it's a terrible hoax and it should never
have
been to another president again because
many of them would not be able to handle
it I don't care who they are many of
them would not be able to handle do you
think Joe Biden could handle it I mean
Joe Biden right now he looks like he's
got some big problems but do you think
can you imagine if this happened to Joe
Biden it wouldn't be good but it should
never happen to another president what
happened to me and it should never
happen nobody should ever allow this to
go forward again and people have to
learn there has to be a lesson taught it
has to be a lesson taught should never
be left so bad for our country mr.
president I have a question about this
because you didn't invoke executive
privilege you handed in 1.4 million
documents you encouraged your staff to
cooperate with Congress to cooperate
with Muller I'd never like Muller's team
I could not for the life of me
understand how does he hire Andrew
Weissman the worst record of any lawyer
I've ever seen people like Jeanne ray
who was once Clinton's lawyer on the
Clinton Foundation and you gave written
answers everybody you even let your
White House Counsel magan testify for 30
hours I was a little shocked to be
honest why would you allow that I let
everybody testify I wanted to be totally
open because I knew there was nothing
there there was nothing there nothing at
all but you know Bob Bauer was
conflicted because he wanted to be the
head of the FBI the director again he
was already there for 10 or 12 years but
he wanted to be and I I didn't allow
that I said no I said it respectfully we
had a business dispute in the private
life when he was out of the FBI we had a
commercial business dispute I had a bit
how about having a business dispute with
somebody think of this and then he's
supposed to be ruling on you but it was
a business dispute and it was a nasty
little dispute you know not the biggest
one I've ever been in to be honest with
you but we had a real business dispute
so you look at that that's a total
conflict of interest how can somebody
where you have a dispute be ruling
and his best friend who are very close
to it is Comey and Kobe played a big
part of this because became didn't do
anything without call me McCabe was
totally dominated by Comey he did
nothing Andrew McCabe was a bad guy but
Andrew McCabe did nothing without
calling call me he wouldn't there's an
expression he wouldn't go to the
bathroom without getting poked Omi's
approval and so commis in and brennan
you take a look at Brennan you took over
the horrible rhetoric the horrible the
horrible words he used excused you of
trees who said that he said well I guess
I was misinformed you know he was making
all these predictions and then when the
it said no collusion in the Muller
report which is amazing because they had
18 people that that were Hillary Clinton
people that I I think all of them
actually were anti Trump people in one
form or another
but many of these people they gave to
Clinton's campaign one or two of them
were at including Weissman were at the
event which turned out to be as you know
her Kuwait's it was a funeral it was
supposed to be a party at the convention
center in New York Attorney a victory
party yeah that's so cool exciting
looking scene I saw the same scene as
you did but think of it Bob Mahler was
great friends with call me right there
there's a conflict he wanted the FBI job
and we had a business dispute and I
would tell everybody who'd listen I told
you a long time ago I said how could he
be doing this but despite that let him
do it I said let him do it because I had
nothing to do and they know that they
don't know that I had nothing to do with
the Russia I love our country I love our
country by doing this I've sacrificed a
lot I had a very simple life had a great
company great everything everything was
great I'd sacrifice left but I've made a
tremendous difference here so many
people come up to me Sean and they say
thank you sir for saving our country and
I used to take it with a grain of salt
oh that was a but they say it and they
mean it I went to the other day I was I
was the commencement speaker at the Air
Force Academy incredible young people
and I had
a thousand diplomas to the senior class
that's a lot of shaking hands and
saluting I will tell you is a couple of
hours but it was great but so many young
beautiful people there young people the
beginning of a incredible life they came
up to me they say thank you sir for
saving our country I know exactly what
they meant our country was in big
trouble and we've got to turn now in the
right direction
mr. president just as an aside you did
have a constitutional authority under
Article two with a conflict to fire
Muller who would have been replaced and
I want something right it will be
absolutely two powers I could have done
anything I wanted I don't even bring it
up because we don't even get there
absolutely I have Article two we could
have used that and said I wouldn't even
have to bother talking to you about all
of the other things I wouldn't have to
talk to you about conflicts I could have
fired Muller for conflicts I could have
fired anybody but I didn't want to do it
because they said let it play it play
out it's a hoax it's a hoax what is the
grace and that they're allowed to go
forward with you know interviewing
people having people like kopecks and
others having to pay for a new set of
lawyers same questions went through it
with the Muller report now she was
totally exonerated there was you did
nothing wrong
and now they have to start paying for
lawyers again it's a do-over because the
reporter this would be a mess mr.
president overs this would be the fifth
investigation and you're right people
those Washington lawyers are expensive I
had to hire a few of them in my day but
I just want to say one thing one good
question I want answered is did Italy
did Great Britain in Australia were they
out sourced intelligence-gathering by
high-ranking people not rank and file to
spy on American citizens and circumvent
American laws will be a big question but
I want to I want to change gears here
what are you plane take a look at
Ukraine how come the FBI didn't take the
server Podesta told him to get out he
said get out
so how come
I didn't take the server from the DNC
just think about that one Sean let me
ask you about that one there's 20 Samant
candidates I want to get your general
thoughts on all of them and is there
anyone in particular you prefer to run
against or do you care at all well we
have to see how it plays out I mean
whoever it is it is I don't know I mean
I look at some of them I don't see
George Washington I don't see Churchill
I don't see anybody in particular that I
worry about I think honestly whoever it
is it is we we will George Washington
either you see the polls that came out
today I read a couple of actually
legitimate polls that came out today not
the not the polls that the media makes
up see I'm fighting the Democrats and
the media together it's not and you know
that better than almost anybody but the
people know that I'm fighting the
Democrat Party and I'm fighting the
media their partners their partners I
mean that's why they don't go after
Hillary Clinton with her emails where
she she anybody else would be in jail
for what she did the emails to delete
33,000 emails after you get after not
before after you get a subpoena from
Congress you delete everything so people
never got to see him but the media and
the Democrats are and not all of it but
a big portion of it they're a
partnership and that's disgraceful
so I'm fighting that partnership I'm not
fighting actually fighting the media is
much tougher than fighting the Democrats
if you want to know the truth well mr.
president I call them the media mob and
I you know it's it's for you know
looking for example that's I say it's
every second every minute every hour of
every day and they all lied and they all
fell for the hoax and the conspiracy
theory and they're trying to revisit it
but I want to I want to just ask this
for for the hoax they know it's a hoax
but they write about it anyway they it's
not like they fell for it these are very
smart people they know it's a hoax and
they're right about it
anyway I watch when I have to I just do
it just to get a little ammunition it's
always like
like you know you have to know where the
other side is coming from I watch every
once in a while I'll turn to MSNBC and
I'll see what they say I know most of
the people and it's a fraud they go back
and they meet and what can we make up
remember when they were used to word
everybody used the word manufactured and
every newscast had the word manufacture
but it's not a word associated with what
they were talking about they were
talking about something being
manufactured and every newscast started
with manufactured and they did it with
numerous words they come up with a word
they put it out there all together it's
a really disgraceful situation here's
the good news
we're precedent we've got we've done it
and we're gonna do it again would you
see a crowd like that sure nobody has
seen anything like that I mean not only
the crowd nobody seen this spirit the
spirit and the energy it's been
incredible I say the Republicans have
far more energy you know you hear about
the energy and the Democrats they don't
have energy they're all fighting with
each other I say the Republicans have
far more energy than the Democrats I
really believe that I think they have
all I think a few of them Sergey Demidov
the radical left Dems
a few of these Republicans frankly could
use a spine transplant in my view but I
don't want to go there I know but we
have some great ones too we have some
great ones but you're right there are
some that really should look Nancy
Pelosi hands out subpoenas like their
cookies
Paul Ryan nice guy but I will tell you
when a Jim and when Mark Mark betters
Jim Jordan and Devin and all these
people that great people they're amazing
they're amazing ones when they went to
Paul Ryan to get a subpoena because they
found the same things that we're talking
about Paul would say well let's take it
easy let's not this let's not this let's
come back come back in a week let's see
if we still think about let's do this
it was impossible you couldn't get a
subpoena she hands out subpoenas like
their cookies let me ask you this about
the Democrats they fight a dirtier fight
the Democrats fight a dirty afraid it's
too bad all right so the Democrat
debates begin next we
they're supporting this new green deal
in ten years they want to get rid of the
lifeblood of our economy oil and gas
everything's going to be free they're
talking about a 70 percent top marginal
tax rate for individuals a 90 percent
top marginal rate for businesses and a
wealth tax on top of that and then when
you die you got to pay a tax and again
everything is free they all seem to
support some version of it and Medicare
for all but you can't buy private
insurance according to say Kamala Harris
how did Obama care work out for
everybody but what is your reaction in
this agenda well first of all with
Obamacare we took out the individual
mandate which is the worst part
Obamacare is a disaster and we've
managed it really well that's why you
don't hear so much about it but we've
really done a great job the secretary a
czar has been incredible the way they've
handled Obamacare but I got rid of the
individual mandate which was the worst
thing in Obamacare that's what you paid
for the privilege of not having to pay
for insurance for bad insurance okay bad
health care so you know it's it's just
one of those things no I think I think
that when I meet somebody who even
doesn't like me let's say it's a
business person and they're not Trump
fans I say you have no choice you can't
vote for anybody else because they want
to turn this country over to two I mean
we will be a Venezuela it'll take ten
years or fifteen years but if the wrong
person got in I've turned it around
Shawn I've gotten rid of these rules and
regulations that stifled everything I
approved the Keystone pipeline I
approved the numerous other pipelines by
the way environmentally good as opposed
to trains running across you know the
plains and all of the other things no I
approved so many different things that
are actually good do you know that a
report came out our water in our air
today is cleaner than it ever was
because in many respects we're great
environmental it's not like I'm an
environmentalist but a different kind a
real environmentalist but our water is
crystal clean our air it's the best that
ever was
we would agree sir we do all need to be
good stewards of the greatest country
God gave man are you really gonna live
twit hey we gonna be you really gonna
live-tweet these democratic debates sir
I wasn't going to but I read about it in
the Wall Street Journal or someplace
says it's just fake news no I wasn't
even thinking about it maybe I will now
I mean you know might as well make them
right but no I couldn't cast my vote I'm
a yes I think it would be a great idea
let's go questions they read about it
though as though as fact I never even
thought about it it's just ridiculous
but you know maybe I'll do it
instead of fake dudes I'll make them
correct news and that's okay I think it
would be a good idea to be very
interesting actually I see for example
that you promise that ice next week
we'll begin the process of removing
millions of people that didn't respect
our law laws border sovereignty ninety
percent of the heroin in this country
comes across that southern border now
fentanyl
we're losing three hundred people a week
in this country and my question to you
is there are some people that will ask
me about you and they'll say well you've
known them for over two decades which I
have and I've known you a long time and
you said he'd be conservative and you
were right and we didn't believe you and
you're pro-life and you conservative
justices and tax cuts and deregulation
and energy independence all things I
believed in 30 years of media so now
you're fighting for the border wall but
people say well maybe Donald Trump
should maybe tweet a little less and not
fight so much on the personal level and
but yet it takes a fight against China
against Mexico you were kind of standing
alone saying you'd hit them with tariffs
if they didn't it stopped this this
these migrations from happening
so my question to you is how do you
respond to that that people want and you
I guess to turn off the switch that you
fight for the borders and you fight for
your agenda and but they don't want you
to maybe fight on Twitter well if I
don't have I don't use the word Twitter
I say social media if I don't use social
media I have outside of you and a few
other great people I call them Patriots
actually but you're not really Patriots
as much as you want ratings that means
you getting great ratings and all
fairies doing it's like last
night you got tremendous I heard the
speech ratings you put it on that was an
easy night you and you know just do it
and you did it and it was a great
evening but no I I think I view it as
social media as as a way of getting the
word out look when you have the lies and
the frauds committed by the other
networks many of the other networks you
look at what's going on it's it's
disgraceful this way I get the word out
and I'm getting it out strongly I mean I
have hundreds of millions of people that
see this Plus as soon as I do a tweet it
gets broadcast even on the places that
you would least expect it because
they're desperate for news you know
they're desperate to do anything for
news so it's really a way of getting the
truth that because the media is just got
loco they are they've lost all control
they don't even call up for fact-check
you know I remember 10 years ago 15
years ago I actually used to get great
press if you want to know the truth but
10 or 15 years before I just had to
become a politician and run on a
conservative basis because that's what
it is that's what that's what we're
doing so well it that's why the country
is doing so well now you know we're
probably doing went better right now the
our economy wages are up haven't gone up
in years and decades wages are up over 3
percent think of things the things that
have happened the jobs the unemployment
the amount of people working companies
are pouring back into our country from
Japan
they're coming back from frankly they're
coming back from China because of the
fact I put the tariffs on in order not
to pay the tariffs they're coming back
into this country so many things are
happening but the way I get the word out
is through social media and it's a great
thing I don't know that I would have
been successful if I didn't have it and
you know when I make a speech like last
night there was a fantastic woman right
in the front she had please keep
tweeting mr. president it matters that
was her sign please keep tweeting it
matters and I think it does matter I
don't do it because I enjoy it I do it
because when somebody says that outright
lie on MSNBC or CNN both of whom are
really suffering in the ratings which is
very interesting it's incredible because
they've lost credible
but when they put out lies I can
counteract those lies and I have many
more followers than they do such a great
ask you you know you you said you're
gonna begin the process of removing
millions of illegal immigrants I also
want to get to the status of the border
wall I know there's been miles repaired
and miles built you know is it going to
be finished with your first term because
they were not able to override your veto
and you were able at RIT you were able
to reallocate funds so as you know the
Democrats are doing everything possible
to stop the wall and they lost a big
lawsuit last week we are one a big big
lawsuit against Nancy Pelosi in the
house it was the house actually brought
a lawsuit can you believe that the house
the Democrats Nancy Pelosi brought a
lawsuit and we won the lawsuit as you
probably read we will have but we have
four other lawsuits against us all semi
related and related to each other we are
building a tremendous wall right now
we're renovating vast areas of wall
that's essentially collapsed but it's
good if you renovate you still have a
lot of money by renovating it but and
we're taking down wall and putting up
new walls some areas you can renovate
but we'll have over 400 miles of wall
built by the end of next year which is
very quick it's rapidly approaching we
have three sections being built right
now we're building them in sections in
different areas in different states New
Mexico has a tremendous problem with
people pouring across New Mexico and I'm
hearing that because of this New Mexico
is actually in play for me and for the
Republicans because of what's happening
it's horrible what's happening under
though we have been sections that
started and are about to start in New
Mexico we just finished San Diego as you
know San Diego in California they're so
happy that Mayor was just up in my
office a great guy and he he came up to
thank me for having done the wall
because it's made such a difference he
said it's like day and night he said
people are flowing across and now nobody
can come in well let me ask you this
able to design and redesign the wall
where it's stronger bigger higher you
know it's actually got a little bit
higher if you're
remember that but it's a better wall
that it cost less money it's actually a
stronger world cost less money so we're
doing really well with the wall and it's
a very important element and we're doing
well overall and we're going to start
removing all these people that came in
because the Democrats will not under any
circumstances they won't fix Asylum
asylums a big problem
they won't fix it we could fix it in 15
minutes and they won't get rid of the
loopholes because they want us to fail
it's more important than we fail than
the country succeed and you have drugs
and you have all these other things but
what we're doing is as the people come
out and as we get the necessary
paperwork we're moving people out of the
innards of the country and we're
bringing them back and the countries
that see this and they see it happening
it starts it's already said it but it's
really starting in a much heavier
fashion next week
it's gearing up it's it's you know
sending a signal that you may get in but
you're not getting in for long and
you're going out and the other thing
finally is Mexico for the first time
ever for the first time in you know many
many decades they are respecting us and
we had a big fight and it worked out
great there's 6,000 soldiers on the
southern border on their southern border
stopping people from coming in and
they've been really stepping it up and
you know frankly I was gonna put tariffs
on if they didn't if they didn't do that
I would have put tariffs and I still
will if they don't but they've been
doing a really good job and people that
the border will tell you that the
traffic has really dropped down so a lot
of good things are happening but if the
Democrats would meet for 20 minutes 15
minutes I always say used to be 45 it's
just a very short meeting we could solve
the border problem but they don't want
to do that because they think it's bad
public politically I think what's bad
Shawn what's really bad is what they're
doing I think it's terrible politically
people come in it's crime it's drugs we
can stop it all so fast but we're gonna
stop it anyway even if we don't have the
Democrats
I say that Nancy Pelosi is speaker a
name only in congresswoman Alexandria
Acacio Cortez has really become the big
star and she even got Joe Biden they've
come up with a new green deal plan what
are your thoughts about her and
congresswoman Omar and the position that
Nancy Pelosi is a I don't really agree
with you I think they're cheap Pelosi
probably has control of it I hear
different things but I really think she
does and she knows what she's doing and
so we'll see how it all comes out but
look we have the u.s. MCA the Mexico and
Canada trade deal which is a phenomenal
deal for our country and it's it's good
for them too but it's a phenomenal deal
for our farmers and manufacturers and
even unions everybody wants it so the
Democrats could do that in a bipartisan
way Mexico just approved it today you
probably heard they just approved it
their house just approved it in a big
vote so you know we're just waiting to
see whether or not they'll put that up
for a vote everyone think of it can you
imagine if they didn't is this something
that everybody wants it'll be a very
bipartisan approval but I ask you all of
the folks in the house they have to put
it up for a vote and it'll voted great
for the farmers everybody wants them to
do it so we'll see again do they want to
do what's right for the party and they
can take credit for that bill because
frankly let's make it bipartisan we'll
all vote for it but it's a big bill
Canada's approving it Mexico just
approved it a very very big deal and it
means hundreds of billions of dollars to
our country and thousands and thousands
of jobs and it replaces NAFTA one of the
worst trade deals ever made let me ask
you about foreign policy if I may you
made promises to Israel Jerusalem's now
the capital many other presidents
promised that they didn't deliver you
recognized goal on which other people
promise and didn't delivery you promised
you get us out of the Iranian deal I
don't think you got to drop 150 billion
dollars in cash and other currency on
the tarmac of mullahs that chant death
to America I worry about Iranian
hegemony I worry about Iranian proxy
wars and terror I worry about they're a
lion
with Vladimir Putin and I'm not sure
where China shakes out in all of this as
you look at the geopolitical work up
there
Iran Russia China tell me your concerns
don't worry about a thing everything's
under control don't worry about a thing
you're right we did that for Israel
Jerusalem as you know every president
said we're gonna you know you move the
embassy to Jerusalem becomes the capital
of Israel every president said we're
going to do we're going to do it none of
them did I did it the Golan Heights for
52 years they've been talking about the
Golan Heights I did it they didn't do it
and I understand why because you get
here there's a lot of people calling
begging you not to do it from other
countries heads of countries but
presidents of all practically all said
they're going to do Golan Heights are
gonna do Jerusalem they didn't do it and
then terminating one of the worst deals
ever made the Iran deal that was made by
President Obama paid 150 billion paid
1.8 billion in cash I terminated that
and Iran is a much different country I
will tell you much different today that
when I took over when I took over it
looked like there was no stopping them
right now you said you'll never get
loose I would say if I were you don't
worry about a thing
what about Putin and China well they
were forced together by President Obama
and you never like to see that but they
were forced together by his attitude and
by what they did and when I got here
they were getting very close but we're
doing things that nobody will be able to
even compete with in so many different
ways second of all we're gonna have a
good relationship with Russia and we're
gonna have a good relationship with
China it's very important that we do
they're powerful nations and we're a
very powerful nation and I've rebuilt
our military to a level that nobody
thought possible 716 billion dollars
last year nobody thought it was depleted
when I got in it was they had planes
that were so old they couldn't fly and
our military is almost completed in
terms of
we built and we are doing missile and
missile technology that nobody's even
seen before we announce it or do we not
announce it but we have tremendous you
know the levels of sophistication like
you've never seen with all of that being
said I want to get along with Russia and
I think we will I want to get along with
China and I think we will a meeting
actually both of them next week in Japan
at the g20 and United States gets along
the Russian witch-hunt really hurt us in
terms of our relationship with Russia I
think it was just hurt I think it hurt
us in terms of relationship with a lot
of people but we have very good
relationships with countries and
sometimes what countries that you
wouldn't think so because I've said you
got to pay for NATO you know the United
States wasn't paying for NATO you had a
lot of countries that were delinquent in
their payments to NATO I got them to pay
over a hundred billion dollars toward
NATO but I think that we're going to get
along with a lot of countries but those
two in particular I think we're gonna
have a good relationship but we're a
country again and we're respected again
Sean I hate to interrupt you but I
actually took 50 minutes of Laura
Ingraham show but I want to tell you not
be happy so now it's her birthday today
sir and thank you for being with us
Laura or happy birthday from me and you
the president I think would like to wish
you happy birthday
hey mr. president thank you happy
birthday wow that's great known each
other a long time and congratulations on
your show it's a big success Laura I
appreciate it thanks so much mr.
president and if you wanted to stay on
for another few minutes that's fine but
I don't want to take Hannity's interview
and take the baton baton we hand off to
Laura I want to thank you both because I
tell you what you're great Patriots you
love our country and you know what's
happening and I really appreciate it and
so does everyone else and that's why you
do as well as you do they do appreciate
it they they really get it the people of
the
country they get at this smart mr.
president did you did you get briefed on
this Syrian attack or planned attack on
a Christian Church in Pittsburgh out I
mean this news broke this evening and it
just heard about it in little detail and
I'm gonna meet a little bit later about
it actually tonight it looks like a
tragedy was averted thankfully that's uh
yeah that's right another another
concern mr. president thank you so much